in Jiu Jitsu Kai is in the Gojo Clan has
a long history that goes back over a
thousand years but despite that
satirogoji was the only one who gets any
screen time because of this it's easy to
forget that the rest of his family even
exists which is why today I'll be
explaining literally everything there is
to know about them starting off a
thousand years ago the origin of the
Gojo Clan can be traced back to a guy
called mitchizane suguara according to
Panda michizani was a big shot Jiu Jitsu
sorcerer during the hayen era which is
the Golden Age where Sorcerers and
curses were stronger than at any other
point in history to be a big shot in
those days means that michizani must
have been unbelievably powerful and in
jjk volume 0 we got the reveal that both
Gojo's family and yusu's family are his
descendants this helps to explain why
they each have nearly unlimited amounts
of cursed energy since their ancestor is
generally one of the best Sorcerers of
all time what makes this even crazier is
that michizani suguara was a real person
who actually existed and the story of
his death ties in nicely to
born in the year 845 michizani was
acknowledged as a child genius who could
read and write classical poetry by his
mid-20s he easily passed the exams to
become a government official where he
rose through the ranks faster than a
normal person would thanks to his many
talents he earned the respect of Japan's
Emperor UDA who rapidly promoted
michizana into important jobs including
ambassador to China however many of the
other Nobles felt threatened by his
success and so in the 10th Century they
falsely accused him of treason by this
point Emperor UDA had retired and was
replaced by his son who was more than
willing to banish mishizani from the
capital over the next two years he then
went through hell before dying in the
year 903 and after his death this is
when strange things began to happen for
example one of the Nobles who'd falsely
accused him was struck by lightning and
killed while another one suddenly died
of illness on top of that the politician
who replaced michizani passed away after
falling in a swamp and the Emperor who
banished him lost his son and Grandson
within a short period of time in fact on
historical records the cause of death
for the emperor's son was implied to be
the curse of michizani as they believed
that his vengeful Spirit was behind all
the chaos this is what brings us back to
jjk where we know that humans can turn
into curses after death depending on the
circumstance in michizani's case he had
unfinished business with the Nobles who
framed him and since he wasn't killed
with cursed energy his soul was able to
return as a special grade vengeful
spirit in this form he became feared for
causing natural disasters like floods
and earthquakes but his most well-known
attack was lightning on more than one
occasion lightning struck different
people who'd betrayed him and for that
reason it's my personal theory that when
michizani was alive he had fully
mastered the Limitless curse technique
season 1 of Jutsu Kaizen hinted that
lightning can be a natural byproduct of
hollow purple and so if a sorcerer is
skilled enough they might be able to
harness that lightning as an extension
technique an extension technique is when
someone creatively uses their power in a
way that deviates from its normal
purpose with one example being how
Megami created flying toads and another
example being how nobra created those
cursed energy grenades out of the nails
given that michizani is a legendary
sorcerer with 30 years more experience
than Gojo currently has I say there's a
decent chance that lightning could be
one of many extension techniques that he
derived from the Limitless if this
theory is correct then it would also
mean that michizani had the sick size
which is a quirk that enables you to see
cursed energy on a microscopic level
throughout history only people from
Gojo's bloodline have had this mutation
and according to the author the six size
is mandatory if you're using Limitless
therefore as Gojo's most famous and
possibly most powerful ancestor we can't
ignore the possibility that they had the
same curse technique and if they did the
michizani would have had the six eyes as
well now moving on to roughly a century
after his death this is when a new six
side from the Gojo family appeared
before we get into it though I should
warn you that from this moment we will
be talking about spoilers from the manga
so if you don't want to know anything
after season two then now is the time to
hit that sub button and check out a
different video on the channel for
everyone else the first place we need to
look is chapter 145 where we got some
important information about tengen in
case you don't know tangin is the
immortal sorcerer who's been alive since
before the hay and era even began and
she claimed that her Destiny is directly
connected to Sorcerers who have the sex
eyes to explain why we need to
understand her immortality curse
technique which is an ability that
prevents her from dying but still allows
her to get old after 500 years of Aging
her body began to evolve into something
inhuman and so to stop that Evolution
from happening she reset her body by
absorbing another person the person she
absorbed was referred to as the star
plasma vessel and throughout the
timeline there have been at least three
different star plasma vessels who were
chosen to merge with tengen if we do the
math the most recent merger was supposed
to happen in 2006 meaning the merge
before that must have happened in the
early 1500s and the one before that was
around the year 1000. this is where the
six eyes comes in because during that
very first merger around the year 1000
it was the six size who saved the star
plasma vessels live the reason he had to
do this is because at the time there was
a mad scientist sorcerer called kenjaku
who desperately wanted to see what would
happen if tengan evolved as a result he
tried to get rid of the star plasma
vessel but chapter 145 confirmed that
kendraku was beaten by the sex size
which allowed the first merger to take
place what's amazing though is that even
though he was beaten he somehow managed
to avoid being killed by the Limitless
this gave kunjaku the time he needed to
rethink his plan and for the next 500
years he waited until tengan had to
merge for the second time as a quick
side note konjoku is not Immortal but he
has the ability to artificially extend
his life thanks to his curse technique
which lets him take over people's bodies
anyway like I was saying around the
early 1500s Tangen had gotten so old
that she needed to do another merger but
kunjaku had been plotting to make sure
it wouldn't happen on the this occasion
he didn't want to take any chances and
so he somehow infiltrated the Gojo
family and killed the six eyes less than
one month after they were born he did
this to guarantee that they would never
grow up to defeat him in the future and
then he took things a step further when
he eliminated the baby star plasma
vessel by doing all of this it meant
that when the day of tengen's evolution
arrived there should have been nothing
and no one who would have stopped it
however almost like a miracle on the day
a new six size in New Star plasma vessel
showed up defeating kinjaku once again
and enabling the merger to happen based
on the way tangin described these events
my guess is that following the death of
the original baby sex size a second six
eyes was born shortly after which the
goja family kept a secret normally this
level of secretiveness isn't something
they do but considering how the first
baby was assassinated it makes sense why
they'd use every trick imaginable to
keep this next one under the radar if
this is the case it had perfectly
explain why kinjaku never knew that a
new six size was around because no one
would have expected that another one
would be born so soon remember in the
present day Saturday was the first six
eyes to appear in over a hundred years
so clearly they don't show up very often
the fact that two would appear back to
back is a miracle like I said and it's
why tengen believes that she's connected
by Fate to the sixth size and the star
plasma vessel now moving on to the early
1600s this was the beginning of the Edo
period in Japan which is an era that
lasted for over 250 years during this
time the gojos had at least one more
sorcerer who inherited the Limitless
curse technique and the story of his
death is pretty interesting in a recent
interview it was revealed that if
someone has the Limitless and sex eyes
then they automatically become the head
of the Gojo Clan and it was implied in
the manga that the Zenith are the same
and that they choose their leader purely
based on who has the 10 Shadows back in
the Edo period this was the case in that
both heads of the family had those curse
techniques and for some reason or the
other they got into a fight in front of
the other Nobles the argument then ended
up descending into a death match and
based on the hint that we got in chapter
117 to me it sounds like the leader of
the Zenon realized he was going to lose
and so he decided to at least make sure
that the head of the Gojo clown would
die with him that's why he used the 10
Shadows to summon maharaga which is of
course the one chikagami that knows
Xenon has been able to control because
it has the ability to adapt to literally
anything the only way maharaga can be
beaten is if he quickly destroy it with
an attack that it's never seen in that
sense the head of the Gojo Clan had a
chance of survival if he'd immediately
use something like Hollow purple but
sadly for him he just wasn't able to get
the win as a result both Clan heads were
killed in front of everyone and ever
since then the Gojo and Zenon families
have hated each other this Mutual hatred
is something that's persevered all the
way up until the modern day and we see
this with an albito Zenon who was the
head of the zening clan as in chapter
106 he didn't even care that Gojo was
sealed and he was kind of interested to
see how the Gojo clown would decline in
the wake of their you know their leader
disappearing speaking of the modern day
is now finally time to talk about the
currency size and the remaining members
of his family in 1989 the birth of
satorogo changed the entire Jiu Jitsu
world with his existence forcing many
curse users to go into hiding at the
same time his curse energy was so
overwhelming that her spirits began to
get stronger in response which is partly
why special gray Spirits now appear way
more frequently than they used to
according to the author as a child
Saturday was treated like a king by the
rest of the Gojo Clan but even at that
young age there were outside forces who
wanted to kill him chapter 96 showed us
that there was a bounty of over a
hundred k for any assassin who could
terminate kid Gojo but obviously that
didn't end up happening then when
Saturday was 16 tengan was on the verge
of evolution and so she desperately
needed to merge with a new star plasma
vessel the name of that new vessel was
riko Amani and Gojo's job was to defend
her from any threats just like his
ancestors had done in the past
ultimately though he did fail in that
mission with Rico being murdered by toji
fushiguro who was a an assassin without
any cursed energy toji was hired to kill
the gull by a wealthy religious
organization and it was explicitly
confirmed in the manga that kanjaku was
secretly behind it rather than trying to
kill the star plasma vessel himself
kendraku instead pulled the strings of
this religious organization which is why
in this scene it's revealed that the guy
who told you thought was the boss isn't
actually the one in charge following on
from that with the star plasma vessel
being dead tengum was forced to evolve
and she gradually morphed into this
creature that was more of a curse Spirit
than a human this was good news for
kanjaku because about a decade later he
stole the body of sugru gato and in the
process gained the ability to manipulate
curse Spirits with this power the
villain had everything he needed to
manipulate and experiment with tengan
even more but before he could get to
that he wanted to get rid of satiro as
we know kanjaku has a terrible track
record when it comes to facing off
against the sex eyes and in chapter 222
he just straight up admits that he'd die
if he fought against Gojo that's why
instead of a fight he decided to trap
Row in the prison realm which was a
genius idea for one reason in this
series only one living person is allowed
to have the six eyes at any given time
so by trapping him in the prison realm
forever a new six size would never be
born again in that way kinjaku had
learned from his mistakes 500 years
earlier and he was trying to guarantee
that he'd never have to deal with this
similar situation where a music size
appears after he's already killed one
regardless after sasero was sealed this
is when we learn a little bit more about
his relatives in the present day in
chapter 148 it was mentioned that there
are people inside the Zenon Clan who
want to improve their relationship with
the Gojo Clan proving that even with
satro being gone there are still living
members who were active in the Gojo
family later on the Zenon Clan is then
basically wiped out with the exception
of Maki and Megami and when this
happened the gojos made a formal request
that the zenings be removed from the Big
Three Families what makes this funny is
that at the time the Gojo clown was
incredibly weak themselves with their
leader being trapped inside the prison
Realm during the Shibuya Arc the family
were described as literally being a
one-man team so you think that when that
man is out of the picture they'd be a
tiny bit more humble one last thing to
mention is that when Saturday was a kid
his relatives taught him how to use
falling Blossom emotion which is a
special anti-domain technique that's
only known by Sorcerers in the big three
Clans anyhow if you made it this far
then thank you for watching and don't
forget to check out my other video where
I explained all the different curse
techniques in the Zenon Clan also I'd
appreciate if you liked and share this
video if you liked it and until the next
one peace out